a few months ago I participated in a
debate contest in school and we
discussed whether artificial
intelligence use is beneficial for human
feature artificial intelligence is type
of computer technology which is
concerned with making machines work in
an intelligent way similar to the way
that human mind works
so I belong to the team which opposes AI
use actually I wanted to be in the
protein because for what reasons to yo
fozzy is I mean it exists to help us
right but there were too many people who
want you to be in the pro team and I had
no choice but to be in the opposite team
so our team started information about
side-effects of AI and actually we
stayed up all night doing the research
because our teacher only gave us gave us
one day to prepare with it for the
debate I usually think every experience
is worth it but not this time anyway in
the first debate we argued that AI takes
on human jobs and finally it will
dominate human and the other team said
AI is perfect in all way and Roth will
develop if human keeps using it we
fought really hard and finally were in
the third place after the debate one of
the facts I learned is that many jobs
which are done by humans are now being
done by AI suppose we have a choice you
can either ask your brother to help you
with your math homework by the way
you're not sure how good a math is or
you can ask a super bot who will you
choose please raise your hands your
brother your super but thank you now you
can lower your hands like all of you
many people chooses superable for work
due to its effectiveness and accuracy
however there are many fields in human
jobs which is required subjective
decision and the wall section is a very
case since I was little I've heard a lot
of cases to my father who is a judge and
he told me that many judges are so
Jack Duvall working whether they intend
to be or not for example George is a
defendant ship in jail for two years
while judge pieces one year is enough
this is because all judges think
differently about the same case and in
this respect human tends to be more
subjective while AI is objective in
doing work we can easily see computers
dealing in objective tasks but now AI is
allowing certain fields to remain
subjective tasks as well including the
justice system have you ever heard of
Rus intelligence
raus intelligence is the first AI lawyer
which collects and analyzes leading
cases even though some people say that
lawyers can be replaced by AI warriors
are concerned about the extension of AI
use in a point that it is unable to
understand individual cases similarly
according to a research team in Oxford
George as a job is the risk of
disappearing by advent of AI as
artificial intelligence is quickly
spreading all over the world
Robert Raj which is able to reflect
about hundreds of cases is likely to be
developed in the near future let me give
you an example
your impoverished and living with your
daughter who is only two years old
one day she is crying because she's
hungry but you find no money in your
pocket so you determined to go to market
and still some milk powder you get
caught and you're arrested and put on
trial with a I charge for sentences you
exactly the same way it sentences a
person who's still TV of course I might
give you an extreme example but this
kind of situation can actually happen
considering the properties of AI
unfortunately we cannot prevent this AI
from being introduced into our world
because the extension of AI use is like
a general trend so you should find a way
to take advantage of AI in more
effective way in the future there are
several ways that AI might be used
Oh judgement in current system first
lawyers and judges are human one
possible option for future is that a
defendant might be able to choose
whether they want a a judgment or human
judgment first is when defendant want
themselves to be judged by only human
judgment 100% in this case a judge can
listen to the argument of the accused
and understand the individual cases if
the accused wants a ruling which allows
for subjectivity he or she might prefer
100% human judge with no AI but allowing
for human subjectivity also leaves room
for human prejudice throughout history
many cases have been affected by the
prejudice of human making legal decision
like all white juries in cases against
african-american defendants and in civil
rights era in the United States
well this circumstance actually happens
these days because of the subjectivity
of judgment in these cases our ruling
from AI may be fair because it might be
more objective through the system which
delivers automatically by considering
the information and evidence they will
be likely to be sentenced without being
swayed by judges prejudice I think
George is the very job with cold seasons
of AI and human because it needs both
subjectivity and objectivity not only
for judge prose for other jobs we should
not bring in a I are not faithfully and
let it dominate human human jobs AI can
benefit a world but we should not forget
that it is like a double-edged word and
there should be detailed restrictions to
use it effectively thank you
[Applause]